[Musique]
benoît achète une maison ancestrale et
son assureur veut évaluer les risques
les il envoie une inspectrice qui
constate que la cheminée doit être
rénové pour respecter les normes
d'aujourd'hui
l'inspectrice donne deux mois à benoît
pour effectuer les travaux
benoît doit respecter cette condition
pour être assuré et il doit faire
parvenir à l'assureur une confirmation
écrite
benoît fulmine c'est une dépense
imprévue
alors il décide de signer le document et
de l'envoyer à l'assureur même s'il n'a
pas fait les travaux
il se dit que les assureurs font bien
assez d'argent comme ça mais ce qui
devait arriver arriva
l'assureur s'est rendu compte que
l'incendié a été causé par la cheminée
et si un assureur peut établir que vous
avez été de mauvaise foi il en
l'argument parfait pour ne pas payer
c'est son droit le fin mot de l'histoire
penser que l'assureur n'y verra que du
feu est un jeu dangereux